[Music]
you ever write some stuff and you
realize oh I did years ago you wrote
your same joke over and over again
yeah yeah and it's more it's like more
like it might just repeating a mantra to
myself that's about believing in
yourself or looking for magic in the
world like I don't even joke anymore
you're just trying to keep yourself
alive with your own philosophy that's
how many songs can be about the same
thing and that's acceptable but if you
like hack your own stuff comedy wise
it's like man I'm a fraud that's why I'm
upset too I wish they would
I wish somebody knew myself like I could
keep doing the same thing I mean I could
keep just Jeff Foxworthy and myself yeah
over and over I was this catchphrase get
er done that was the other one his you
might be a red alright get er done
that's Larry yeah those guys fill
stadiums with that and I gotta come up
with fresh stuff so I could sell 200
tickets in Cleveland and if you do you
repeat one bit oh yeah god forbid
somebody wants to hear a hit or if you
do if you don't do it like if you do bad
and people like man remember that I
think this is an ego thing but if
somebody comes like but they like a real
whole bit my golf my go off a thing I
did in 2012 ago man that joke about
pancakes in a plane I'm like yeah man I
had like four more hours well he want to
top myself I want to progress well also
with stories I've found that it's just
especially if it is to be a few years
old it's tough to recreate oh yeah same
energy that you had about that thing
that you yummy
you carried that energy for probably a
year of touring but I feel I can't I'm
not a Salesman I can't sell it if I'm
not into it right look a bit so like
that's a problem the record like I don't
even record a special one I'm like this
is great I'm like I'm real sick of this
and I just need to do something else so
just put it out like this is all good
this is gonna get real bad real soon
I got a shelf life for jokes a real long
shelf life because they'll be laughs at
it I love doing it and you're doing it
for yourself yeah I still keep talking
about how Margaritaville is the saddest
song that's ever been made and nobody
laughs at that joke it's my favorite
joke in the world
[Music]
searching for my love sugar so
Jimmy Buffett song yeah but if you if
you sing it about Margaritaville but the
actual restaurant instead of a fictional
place that's a real dark song and I
don't know if it's just like I don't
think either part like you don't know if
a jokes funny anymore yeah
like is it just was it just never funny
or do they not get it like I think it's
hilarious that a guy would just be it
like City walk in that Margaret like
still yelling about is like divorce and
stuff like real sad like that's
hilarious to me yeah but a guy's saying
that like a place that's kind of like a
Chili's in Schaumburg that's the saddest
thing in the world if a guy sitting
there crying into his coconut I think
that's what I've thought for four years
but I can't get anybody else on board
not that I see except abou Chicago's on
Kyle Kinane I'm getting like a rap sheet
cago time from this as I was joking
about before like I'm from tornado
country I don't know why I keep getting
Chicago rep I'm much more like getting
the basement skies green like that's the
part of the suburbs up from so I'm from
I'm from the part of Chicago right where
tornadoes start to touch down they
really do they would touch down in
Lombard like one more town out of the
city and that's sort of like oh I
remember my mom would freak alley we saw
a funnel cloud find the camp get in the
basement I'm like that's my street cred
for Chicago all right Addison yeah see
now we're gonna get I don't wanna fall
asleep represent go give our listeners
you know more of a knowledge that is
geography of Chicago in a suburban
system Addison is a western suburb yeah
that's off is it off 55 no that's off to
90 to 90 years to 90 the Eisenhower
and that's what Kyle Kinane is from
that's like the jingle for the
Eisenhower right down to 90
you know what jingle I missed from the
from Chicago maître the way to really
[Music]
didn't rap right away and then they came
out with the rap jingle and that was
like when they went next level with
monoi cuz they were like they had the
people in the costumes who were just
kind of they weren't singing cuz they're
in a costume I just remember that was
like next level
I'll go look at the whole date he's like
Chicago like for some reason like Star
beat presents what's happening is one
that I remember from like the old b96
z9t that was like on the radio where the
star be presents what's happening but
what t-shirt contest at Crawford's down
in Alsip and it was all like just the
shitty local promos but they were like
the concert like they were like the
promotion company promoters yeah and
Rihanna firs was the best you gotta feel
the warmth and luxury that you deserve I
got that's been a long time so those are
good lyrics whoever wrote that had bars
they had good Eagle man insurance yeah
it was a big one but they did those but
the thing about Eagle man that I don't
respect those commercials they made of
shitty on purpose
do you think I don't think I think its
first oh I thought at first like victory
auto wreckers I thought at first they
were just bad commercials oh they were
victory is the og they just made bad
commercials ego man was purposefully
making bad commercials so that people
can remember them well at least that's
the story that yeah I thought that man
cow got on top of it
this man cow still around yes yeah man
cow is still around have you done it so
before no no to a show everyone go back
there I forget where I was plays well
you wanna do man cows oh yeah why would
I do that once a few years ago and it
was just chaos but it's like this but
just lots of sound bites super fast pace
though wet with no space as a yeah you
guys jump in well is heat like I get do
you wind up is that just what happens to
those morning DJ guys they get so
programmed into that lifestyle like
that's how they just they become like
free speech activists when people are
just like you're not funny look what
it's freedom of speech like that's okay
but you're just bad at comedy it's not
like we're trying to suppress you know
it's like shock yeah they do shock value
stuff and people are like hey you're
being a [ __ ] Oh freedom was like I
don't know I thought like remember he
was like joking morning show guy and
then didn't he go all alex jones didn't
he go crazy he had a different
perspective when I did the show I don't
remember what was a 2012 assumption yeah
zany shows but it was I just I don't
know if I didn't ask something
I don't even remember to disagree but if
it was with the producer but yeah
I just remember saying I'm never I'm
never doing this again okay if my show
is at ten seats out at the Chicago
theater yeah you think it's gonna be 11
season if you go on man
I'm not going on there you know I
remember I remember doing a call in like
okay you call him what trying to have
characters if I called in and I don't
forget what they have they would just go
Kyle what's up I'm like and I just
started to talk and they were just like
play a fart sound and cut my mic and
when you you know and when you really
think like that's like oh man I'm gonna
be on Mancow in the morning good be on
cue 101 it's like when you don't realize
you're gonna have a career doing
anything I'm regular schools and they
just made fart sounds and I was like
thinking I think my mom was listening so
I don't think they treated you very well
I had this radio guy in in Memphis this
guy I guess he was a comedian too and he
was asking some questions he's like this
question is from a fan or I don't know I
don't I don't ask
he's like okay if you had to if you had
to roofie one of the Cosby daughters
which one you know I said yeah I know
wonderful are you doing right now yeah
yeah I said what's your problem what the
[ __ ] is is yeah so you know you don't
have to be this person's like what was
your like for real you want to do this
yeah well that's I was like is there a
detachment from like you're not getting
any immediate feedback from people and
then like guests feel cornered you know
he's like oh I guess I got to go along
with it's like no you don't you have to
go along with any of that [ __ ] I've done
those like that morning radio all right
well you know like over here's the [ __ ]
and it's just it's a woman who works and
like as part of these it's like that's
the [ __ ] you requited I'm like I'm not
gonna call her that man she's got a
we've got a human name and her parents
mother yeah you don't have to be this
person that's why I just started going
like hog-wild on those things like just
trying to take the reins like I did a
Bob and Tom and like the one time I did
Bob and Tom they wanted
nothing to do with me and so the next
time I showed up just drunk from the
night before just kind of like taking
over every question until like all right
and your segments done I'm like ah Wow
our early alright see you later
energy for that I want to do that I know
that that's and I've seen I can do it
sometimes and I've seen other performers
and entertainers that just have that
energy where they just say no I'm gonna
take control and this is my time you
hear yeah all the time
Buffett is 10 minutes yeah it's me yeah
just run through that [ __ ] Tracy Morgan
does and there's some other people that
just run they come in with a plan or
they don't they just come in with energy
and confidence yeah I guess that's what
you get to do when you're already kind
of untethered from society and don't
have to worry about finances part of me
is like I still got to get people to
come to the show this weekend there's
still real-world income for me I'm still
part of the part of the earth I think
with the morning TV
I did not they're not set up to really
for you to succeed as far as presenting
your comedy and get is not the best of
writers so the only way to really get it
going is just to shift something to make
them unconscious a little thing just sit
in a different seat yeah yeah oh but but
the format well that's why every time
you go in for a radio or something they
look at a little boy you look tired boy
buddy you look we're gonna go out last
night like yeah what the [ __ ] it's 6:00
in the morning this isn't a natural time
that's like you wake a farmer up at
midnight be like tell me about your job
and they're not enthused to do it like
and no [ __ ] this isn't hours that I work
you're messing up my whole day right now
and I'm supposed to be also selling my
product with the worst team yeah wake up
with 2:00 in the morning and sell your
product also are the people that's
listening this at 6:00 in the morning
coming to see my show at 9:00 yeah
that's good I've seen so many people
I've done it too like how many people
heard me on like queue 108 Rodney Rodney
rock-and-roller morning show and nobody
is known like nobody cares yeah so do
you not do them anymore grudging ii-i'll
do like one once in a while where
somebody's like I also feel like this is
pretty arrogant when somebody's like
this is actually a real big radio market
I'm like what's wrong with them
are they dumb who still listen to the
radio who still what there's so many
options out there why he's still come on
Phoenix what's wrong with you never mind
I answered that question but going to
Phoenix the way I've you I did a run cuz
we got into Memphis I had it so I did a
few interviews that day but the way I've
tried to make it more productive is just
bring my own video guy and film the
stuff for myself too and then I put it
up okay and you can cut it up how you
wanted or you know what I mean you have
it for whether that time or for the
future and you get more out of it than
yeah if you did something real silly and
fun you get yeah you still you still
have it so filming it for yourself
cuz you know some of those radio
interviews you never hear them or they
they don't put them up online
sometimes so and I don't even know what
I say on them half the time because it's
6:00 in the morning I'm just like trying
to put thoughts together and then just
ramble out something like now I regret
that yeah I'm glad nobody has that
recorded this guy brought a children's
book once to one of the race she found a
children's book and started Australia I
just started reading the book during
this interview is born but and just
started going through how superjet found
it I found it outside and I just started
reading through the book I was committed
to the bed
we're gonna go to commercial right now
was it were you there for the festival
you were there just doing your own shows
I did my own shows did a run of shows
yeah December 2016 did people come out
to him yeah get a good following out
there yeah I do like Australia a lot
stro crowds a great man they respect the
flight yeah I think that's a bit is they
like well you have to be good to but
you've been good plus traveling all that
way it means a lot but they have foot
like the audience is like are on board
I've just done the festival's there but
they're like now we're deaf elect their
fun people
Australians are fun people and most
people are witty did you talk to this
person
it seemed like the average person yeah
they're funny they're like well they're
disposition that's how Ireland was I did
that festival in Ireland like why do you
have a Comedy Festival
everybody here is already funny yeah you
don't need even though even a border guy
was [ __ ] with me when I got there cuz
I can't I have trouble going into Canada
and so I like I've got to be very proper
going through his stuff and guys like
well you got a work permit I'm look I
don't I'm just festival is like no work
permit I can't let you know I'm like I'm
sorry I can't bring up the email he's
like I'm [ __ ] with you I'm like
you're like we're in a uniform you're
not supposed to be like the guys like
I'm [ __ ] with you get in here buddy
I'm like alright this place all right
that's some Southeast Asia shows right
yeah I did I did
well I did South Korea hunting that
counts as Southeast Asia I did I did
well no I did a where the hell was I
Malaysia Malaysia I did and then like
wow yeah yeah you've been there
I haven't been its I was like there for
like three days and that was a problem
like you get to go to all these places
touring but then you got to just travel
every day so it's like I'm not even seen
that much stuff right I got to see the
Great Wall of China on my way to the
airport when I was leaving so cool yep
that's a wall and then we got to go to
the airport oh yeah I got to go over
these cool place but I get to see that
much so it kind of bummed I did see that
temple where the monkeys just steal your
wallet
stuffs that's pretty fun like just loose
monkeys they have and they just take
[ __ ] out of your hand if you're holding
somebody just run up and was like this
is pretty fun like that was a unique
experience bring them back to their
masters and sure I don't know how the
monkey hierarchy works I think they just
take stuff cuz they could take it and
then they just run off no it's not like
they're trained to steal for humans
that's not they're just shitty animals
that just sit on the steps others
they're just mean and they sit on the
steps of this temple and just steal your
[ __ ] because they can cuz they're
monkeys and everybody's scared of them
and I'm like these monkeys are small
I'll fight one of these monkeys but then
you look at the numbers of them yeah oh
okay all right I'm not gonna met this
ones over here just baton people and
then the 40 of them it's this temple
that's inside of a cave yeah I like
going to places where you realize like
you're so used to the American standards
and safety standards and you go to a
place like oh this is real dangerous
yeah yeah like there's no way this
should be like this wouldn't be allowed
elsewhere like even just here like when
you go to the Grand Canyon you're so
used to like how safe everything's made
you think like oh there's probably a
railing around the Grand Canyon there's
not you could just fall and die and I'm
like good like that there should be
places in the world where you're your
own capabilities as a human being
determine your life span like look at me
get picture like people die grand canyon
all the time and yeah I'm fine with that
this place I went into like some cave
that was filled like like batsh it's
supposed to be real bad for you and I
was like then this bad like oh yeah
anyway here's tour you're the tour guide
you're doing this every day they make
you wear helmets I need that one safety
goggles anything no no no the only just
walking around throw his bed but then I
was in Mexico and you go these cenotes
like oh there's some out there and like
and they're all the bats up there I'm
like so the bats just [ __ ] in the water
and we're swimming in the water what is
this bad yeah like that gets real toxic
okay yeah it's like a sinkhole there's
like a whole underground river this
water yeah it's all like like saw the
Cancun everything there's all these
like you just see a hole like a cave on
the ground you walk into it they're gone
then there's just pools of water that
you could swim through and underground
caves and they're privately owned like
so if somebody is finds another property
it's like Oh Dave's cenote and he'll
just like all right man give me thirty
pesos and try not to drown in my
property
you know those you when you're in
Thailand and getting all your fish the
fish were eating your feet yeah they're
in the cenotes oh I was in there and I
was swimming around coming up and bitin
my feet and they were they were the same
thing you did the fish the fish bad
thing yeah feels so kind never giggled
more in my life right like tough Arab
dudes getting in there just teeing the
whole time such a crazy
yeah sensation and I wonder I mean a lot
of obviously they that's what they do
but I wonder my feet are rough is [ __ ]
so I wonder if they were going in
crazier cuz my feet were rough oh yeah
this guy need to work and get work so
they know they're not there like that
nature too they're just they're just
vicious there yeah come at you they're
all on my feet it's so yes so they don't
even realize that they're working it's
just yeah they're just hungry it's just
yes next time yeah a little little
tickle massage for your free feet think
that's what they do I think in the wild
I think that's what they do they find a
larger animal and they just start
cleaning their dead skin I wonder who
monetize that who said let's get these
[ __ ] out of here and into here
I want to know who tried to monetize the
next thing after that that failed
miserably just put this eel around your
neck and it just really clears up your
skill like that once went south real
quick
Oh glad they sign that waiver you never
seen Badgers give you a back rub you got
check this out
[ __ ] man we had to close that one right
cuz keep keep with the fish keep with
the fish what bad yeah yes bad Yelp
reviews off of that one yeah we have a
few brother bags I mean for the values
all right though I mean they did refund
our money so I respect them for that
yeah I love I love on the Yelp reviews
too when it starts off with well if I
had the option to give zero stars I
would but let me tell you just anytime I
see like what's the status like Elite
Yelp or a mugging what a what a horrible
person yeah yeah you gotta be looser you
gotta be a terrible person that really
thinks like this is my service isn't
worse but we use that system no we don't
contribute it sounds like you're not a
copper I will go on to it yeah but if
it's reviewed by somebody who reviews
everything in their life [ __ ] that but
if it's one person as one review and
said you know what this restaurant was
great alright I'm like you went out of
your way to praise that restaurant I'm
gonna trust you when you have limited
reviews because you felt strongly enough
to go through that when somebody just
goes through life like that
four stars three stars I'm important
people rely on me for this [ __ ] that
person but somebody goes out of their
way to either be like [ __ ] this place or
it was great I think I got four Yelp
reviews out there yeah and one was for a
restaurant that was good and like if you
give us the Yelp review you get 10% off
so I do that yeah and then the other
three were for businesses that were
garbage and I was like I want people to
know yeah every do you ever go do you
ever go down have you ever gone down a
yelp review or a Yelp wormhole yeah well
I'm trying to think was the last time I
did something like that was yeah why
start like it's more than individual
it's more like I'm curious about the
type of person that rates everything in
their life yeah I like psychotic
yeah well I'm wondering if like was this
Instagram before Instagram so you can
kind of prove that you've been
traveling by rating things and now how's
the Instagram like alright just take a
picture with the Golden Gate Bridge
instead of telling people I ate at you
know House of Nanking and gotta let
people know
yeah you check-in yeah yeah so the
places that are reviewable are is pretty
funny the Hollywood sign has a Yelp page
what and people say oh yeah great views
four stars yeah yeah when it's like a
church or something like like a
historical monument
come on man yeah yeah you really
reviewing Mount Rushmore
our tour guide Louis was it except I
would walk a friend here lots of stars
for me i watch the guys [ __ ] in front of
me two stars Kyle you ever read the
reviews that they leave for you at the
comedy clubs no I was at one club where
people when it's like it was like
feeding frenzy when they dumped all the
tickets out at the end of the night and
everybody rushed to read him my mantle
really I don't need to know that I was a
showcase or just like the people people
that work there was up to par I don't I
mean I guess that's just how you respond
to criticism in general like I mean I
think it's hilarious I mean last time we
were in Nashville the waiter gave me
this piece of paper and it was like this
the worst DJ ever it is disgusting I
don't want to see this here again Wow I
like how you got his voice right I can
only imagine he sounds exactly like that
that you embodied that man perfectly a
guy had Nashville zany's and see it of
Asian DJ that was the correct voice
you really talking about Zanies here
today we talked about Chicago's Amy's
Nashville's Amy's Vernon Hills st.
Charles st. chucks yeah right yeah I
think I'm going back to the Nashville
woman I like Nashville did you the story
about that club that some guy that early
on when I started at comedy club they
accidentally locked a guy in there and
he drank himself to death what yeah I
supposed to be haunted cuz a guy like
that back in the day when they were all
partying in there and they closed up for
the night some guy was passed out and he
woke up alone with all liquor and he
just drank himself to death
yeah Nashville's Amy's he's supposed to
like yeah he's supposed to haunt the
place ain't that sometimes when I look
at a bar say if I drink all that to
remind yourself that's a lot of liquor
a little bit of it is ok but all of it
is bad my drunk is days when it's all
lit when the top shelf of the whole
walls lit and I just look at it I'm like
that's beautiful like that's what that's
what yeah oh that's what church must
look like that like born-again crazy
like oh so much so many different things
the thing is like I drink a bunch I
don't like any of it yeah like I'm never
like you know what I want the flavor of
vodka right now like that's never what I
want to taste alcohol in general what
about like a nice Christmas ice-cold can
of beer
no I cold beers different that's just a
thirst quencher but like when you think
about with like I think I don't know if
I just don't have an expansive palate or
maybe I'm just a rube you know I don't
have the taste but any kind of liquor
like you taste it you were just still
you were just like drink like whiskey or
something just like feel like you're
pretending to be adult around other
people Scott I don't never ever have
Scott this is [ __ ]
this is a good scotch aged that's what I
mean like barrowed the Barrow and they
triple distill like this just sucks
it's taste like garbage
a hundred dollars a shot steel garbage I
taste them like I do taste all the
things you're telling me about a taste
the peat then the mean dirt do you mean
dirt are you using the Scottish word for
dirt because I tasted dirt and I'm like
yeah I don't underst because somebody
put a lot of time and effort into it why
does that mean it's it's not good like
it then never tastes good I drink it I
don't I drink it I'm a drunk I will
drink all of the things but it's never
like I always feel like if you're just
sipping on something I go look at well
look at us I think what Scotch though
it's more of like a special-occasion
thing it's not like I'm just gonna we're
gonna drink this whole bottle of scotch
I think it's more just like a hey let's
celebrate I got this [ __ ] 30 year old
bottle of scotch let's have a drink
I think it's more like dad I don't
really think it's that's why is that Oh
cuz nobody [ __ ] you wanna break into
this old beer everybody drinks that
right away
alright get at it well I don't know
there's a bit the beer the beer game has
changed nowadays you can especially with
like that there's Goose Island makes
that [ __ ] what's that beer that
everybody loves that [ __ ] it's like
it's like coffee and chocolate it's just
thick it's like stout there's some kind
of it's calling Bourbon Barrell stoutish
ah that's Stockholm Syndrome that's like
you don't want to be the one guy at the
craft beer festival it just goes hold on
everybody I think all this stuff sucks
this tastes like somebody ate almonds
and then spit them into the beer and
then strain them out of it
yeah I don't want to I mean and that's
such an easy stance to take like I like
I like wine yeah I love why I'm trying
to be fancier with my life yeah you know
I'll drink a wine I can understand when
why somebody wants to be a nerd about
while ago this came from here and you
could tell difference because of this
I'm like alright everybody's got to have
their interests and you know whether
like whether you're a nerd about
videogames or your nerd about wine I
guess dive into it I don't
why they're not all on the same level I
don't think somebody's more
sophisticated because they know about
wine then then somebody just understands
videogames next a videogame person
probably more sophisticated I don't
think about different plans and
strategies that's what I'm saying why
you just repeating some [ __ ] somebody
else says oh that's a blind test it's
all a justification to just tell
yourself and everybody else that you're
not actually a drunk and you're doing
this for the taste and the experience
but in reality you should just be
drinking handles of vodka and be a man
about it
[Music]
doc is the Alcoholics alcohol yeah
school teachers are putting a coffee
boxer yeah that's like that's the I'm
the down-low booze bags down sullivan
came through once we were I had to fight
on at my crab smell [ __ ] comes through
what I handle the Smirnoff yeah I'm like
CJ nobody's gonna drink this but you
it's like that's the plan these are
kicked off of a flight for being
hungover what it's like yeah you don't
look like you're gonna make it buddy
yeah at that fight party CJ oh somebody
uh CJ took a spill at one point yeah and
I don't know if somebody thought
somebody tripped him I don't know but he
didn't see I didn't witness that when he
went dark because you told me that like
so yeah I ran after you fell he's like
man CJ he's in the dark place right now
all gone any [ __ ] trip say hey man
you wanna you wanna fight again we could
fight if you think but if not I want to
hear about it anymore
at that point Exeter dropped it what he
said yeah Oh funny see he said it so
much I'll let how fight it with you want
the night to move forward pass the zip
[Laughter]
would you uh would you ever open up your
own venue what thought about you trying
to con you try to find your exit from
comedy I'm always thinking about like
what do I want to have on a bar I'm said
it I have pieces together my exit plan
oh you're already good yeah I have soft
exit planned for next two years
oh really let you go did you get real
estate guess real estate some tech stuff
oh really yeah all right we could talk
off air we can't be letting these tips I
don't know I I wonder if like that's a
drunks dream is to open a bar the
dumbest thing like he's I don't know if
I could in my head of like what if I
went to what if I went to a place like a
city that's my thing like what's the
next city that skin it that nobody
realizes is gonna be the spot it's all
so great
I like Tulsa that's all
country yeah but I heard like Cambodia
is coming up as far as like tourism and
all this money's going over there I'm
not even joking what signaling all the
bodies of offense that's a truth man
that country's got a rough history man
Chicago decent I mean Illinois meets
another city you know what I'm saying
yeah another major something by the
South yeah you think so I mean I
what like Rockford wouldn't ape off
anything nearby too much maybe Madison I
sighs my thing is st. Peter I say st.
Petersburg Florida
that's my spot yeah I think what
eventually people got to realize that
you know Florida is cool like Florida
get anything you make fun of the most
will eventually be celebrated ironically
and then it'll be celebrated on
ironically and Florida's a punchline for
everything all the time but eventually
people gonna be sick of the rain and
Portland be like oh you know what I
could be like a craft hip [ __ ] but
also go to the beach and that's nice to
st. Petersburg floor that's my that's my
mark that's a good that's a good
who's there once for an afternoon I made
this whole decision based on one
afternoon yeah I saw one Street where I
was like this is pretty cool Street and
then that's it that's all you need say
Petersburg is next to Tampa right yeah
but it's not all that Tampa's a prison
yard he bore city he bore cities
ridiculous he bore cities like have you
ever been like if you're done the club
in Ybor City well and then you come out
and there's like a death metal bar that
let out next to a Cuban bar that let out
next to a hip-hop night they're gonna
and then everybody's in the streets and
all the gangs in general population and
Coverly I'm like no it doesn't feel good
at all shits gonna pop off like real bad
nothing only weird things have happened
to me
eyeball fest this was this was 2014 and
I was pretty faded and I go into a Jimmy
John's and they were closing up and I
wanted to buy a cookie I was liking that
super hungry so I need some Tampa pushed
you in the thievery makes you a criminal
plus hunger plus alcohol equals I'm
taking his cookie I offered you money
but this is you've given me no choice
I've that I didn't that turned into a
different kind of creep I did a show and
then for some reason it was
this is 2010 or 11 and it was like a
girl was hitting on me but then she was
with her brother and her brother was
being the wingman to the hook-up which I
thought was strange as I can't come back
we're just we're watching a house we're
house-sitting like a brother-sister duo
house-sit I'm like not wanna hang I'm
like I mean I'm pretty desperate but
this is real creepy well here's my phone
number just a case then I got a call
like a day later I get a voicemail and
it's just this real like like filthy
voicemail from a girl like oh that's the
girl my guys drunk and I call I called
back the number she gave me and left a
message like an equally filthy message
okay for this girl what years this
2010-2011 so this is pre Comedy Central
voice yeah yeah yeah so wasn't as
recognized we're gonna make it round but
I love this equally feely voicemail and
then the day I don't hear anything back
and the day after that another comic was
working I was like hey man you get that
voicemail like what are you talking
about his like yeah for sure I was in a
limo and like these playmates throughout
the show and I knew you're in town so I
had him call you and leave you a dirty
voicemail so as my friend just got some
girls to leave me a joke dirty voicemail
and I responded to the number that this
gal left me on an unsolicited super
dirty voicemail I was like I hate this
[ __ ] city man the city makes me creep
does she respond back to no I didn't
hear anything
oh I thought I was just like responding
and kind like alright you left me a
dirty voicemail leave you a dirty
voicemail and then that wasn't it it was
just me being a total accidental perv
like was an accidental perv but you know
I got duped I got I got swindled
[Music]
you are our first guest that is already
but there are many owner yeah
that's excitement yeah yeah I got I like
to roll into a Guitar Center and look at
all the stuff I don't need to know how
to play to play do you have well do you
ever get like you probably get like
production gifts and stuff or you know
like like beat about voice to Comedy
Central then Comedy Central give me some
nice at the end of the year I'm like oh
that's thoughtful form and some really
like like play I dig around on guitar
but I'm not good at it yeah and so they
got me like go get them like a musical
instrument it'll be fun
they got me a full size 88 key keyboard
like so I'm like yeah what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do I can't play that but see no I
get messed up but an 88 key keyboard
that's a lot of space you're taking up
to remind yourself you're not good at
playing music the straight-up keyboard
is the synth what kind of like I just
like as long as this table I'm like
we're gonna put is it like an imitation
piano basic I don't know I didn't even
take it out of the box I did was I just
I brought it back and then I got one of
these because I'm like oh this is looks
like a spaceship and it's fun to just
sit on a table and then when you're
bored or high you just walk by like yeah
you're four you're our first guest
actually that has that owns the theremin
we've had guests near the first one yes
I saw I saw Kyle in New York and that
dude that was one of the funniest [ __ ]
that you ever said to me because there
was a cos during that show of the front
row we're just like you know just a
bunch of [ __ ] really factory yeah
really kunti like privileged white girls
they were just interrupted there were
just terrible people
and then just on the phone and you press
the outside button on them crickets for
his story
no it's enthralling Halloween it's real
passive-aggressive Nam totally
interested in what you said you turned
into the morning DJ we were making fun
accident but yeah those girls were just
like on their phone the whole time in
the front wrong people but then what you
said to me was like you said how did you
say you called them drippy you were like
these [ __ ] drippy [ __ ] in the front
row and use that adjective drippy sighs
ever since trips a bunch of drips people
three shells yeah that's what I don't
even know what their attitude was
they're like they like they act like
when people go to shows like it's like
it's a hip show you know and Kenny
Kenny's doing a great job that yeah
Kenny's hilarious but they're acting
like they're at a cool nightclub it's
like no you're at a show watch the show
don't just be here and think
mission accomplished participate in the
show or [ __ ] off yeah you know the
problem was is they were participating
too much well oh there's people in the
back they were tired but the whole front
row there was one guy I care like that
she didn't smile at anything I became
fascinated with like how much of a unfun
time she was having that's just so weird
when people decide to do the front row
and then just the whole show they're
just like like why are you here I've
always told people yeah I've always told
people like listen I'm not gonna be mad
if you're not having fun at the show
life is short please go and do something
I'm not gonna get mad if you get up and
leave and I want you to make the most of
your life and if this isn't doing it for
if I'm out no offense get out of here go
away
time that's a Friday night we're gonna
make the poop joke if they get up to
step out you don't even bother taking a
[ __ ] yeah I know I think if you can't
handle the truth about this joke yeah oh
I got was guy over here knows yeah why I
hate one like any but I hate that
audiences feel like hostage hostages for
comedy so like I'll go out and like I'll
specifically especially if it's that
like a music venue or something not a
comedy club I'm like get up go to the
bar go to the back because people don't
want to go to the bar because they're
afraid I'm like I'm not gonna say
anything to you I'm glad you're here go
go to the bar go the bathroom and make
you more comfortable to watch Russell
show then I endorse that I'm not here to
[ __ ] with somebody yeah what's the law
what do you think is the longest time
you've spent destroying a heckler I'll
ruin a whole show like you'll do a hack
you've done a half an hour on a heckler
no no I'll just ruin the show in general
like I'll get so mad I was in Amsterdam
that is whole European run with three
cities in England and I did Berlin and I
forget where else I was bouncing around
just you understood yeah and then when I
got to Amsterdam Joe DeRosa was there so
we were co-headlining at the tomb lers
and that's the ever show we had we had
hecklers that were all American and they
were all like you could tell her like
hey we're like being Americans and be
like sciences let me tell ya let me this
is how we do it back in the states like
no that's not how we do it that's when
you were like you realize all these
expats that are so proud of themselves
like I just got out of there it's like
no you didn't have any friends in the
States
you let you act like you're better but
you were you were a loser in the States
so now you think by default that you
move that you're more interesting and
you're not you're a loser here too and
some woman sat in the front row and just
kept answering every rhetorical question
had something to say after every
sentence and everybody kept working on
it like art and and they don't know how
to how hecklers work over there so the
club wasn't doing anything because like
oh no everybody here is already polite
and knows how to keep their [ __ ]
together but this one spilled champagne
on her friend kept interrupting
everything to the point where I'm like
this is a power dynamic you want to know
that you don't have to shut up ever even
though I'm telling you to so here's a
microphone I'm like there's a stage this
is what you want you win and I just when
she just said something did like a mic
drop a boom huh and then the whole club
just staring at her and I was like there
you go there's a response now this is
where I tell the club hey anybody's a
manager get these people the [ __ ] out
that's why I got a kicked out and and
then she of course forgot her phone and
had to come back in the club and then
found me on Facebook to write me a
message about how I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and everything there's a direct route of
communication for [ __ ] idiots when
there are public figures directly access
you dear son so you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah response kicked out I didn't do
anything wrong
I was interacting with the comedian's
enjoying myself don't the word
interacting right there stop you don't
interact with anything at a comment
there's no interactions observation I
don't know if it was a bit or whatever
but your Tomba that the word expat how
come how come that's like a thing for
America specifically Americans in other
countries and then everywhere else it's
immigrant immigrants
it says everybody expats or British
Australian but yeah I guess because it's
temporary they say is expats but
everybody else is immigrant but it seems
like expat is if you're white and move
to a country that's not white expatriate
what does that stand yes this Patriot
does it mean like is it kind of like
like a traitor almost like yeah you're
not a patriot yeah I don't know what I
don't know present the flag anymore
to see like they're immigrants a lot of
them know what if you're a teacher in
English and you lived in out your
immigrant yeah okay I mean I'm a bastard
dirty words so they don't want any you
can't you don't identify with that word
how he uses grip yeah goddamn murder
maybe somewhere for work you know some
people I'm an expat Miami greenhouse I
don't know man I think yeah I think it's
Americans trying to feel special
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta you got a morning routine that
one caught me I was like feeling dude
morning routine our guests like tell us
about your morning routine and then we
go into a song but ya know well I'm not
this this ain't a voice bill for singing
so I don't know I think I do I think I
need one I think I need to get into a
more productive place in my life because
I'm kind of just floating around right
now as I went I did like a three-week
road trip where I was kind of [ __ ]
off and I drove to Colorado and did some
off-roading and was back at 8 o'clock um
no I got a jeep so I was out there being
a cop there's a beater
yeah I'm just being a hillbilly and
driving just just trying to find dirt
roads off in the middle of nowhere and I
just can't for tonight you know is it
one of them jeeps with the [ __ ]
goddamn the bars and it's oh yeah I got
also I got all the stupid [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that somehow malware
got on here and now every once in a
while like all this tech you still got
McAfee checking in on you still got
Norton AntiVirus dropping in seeing how
you doing you know make that part of
your morning routine no man I I think
that I need to set something up to be
more productive because I'm feeling a
little stagnant right now so it's
probably a good idea that I do have one
but I don't right now all right
do you have a morning routine don't
one I want to start I've started setting
more reminders on my phone to do [ __ ]
yeah just [ __ ] that I would forget and
something I still don't do that stuff
but sometimes I do I say do some do some
ab exercises or write or work on that
specific thing I can't sit and write no
I can't I don't know how to just sit and
like write jokes I gotta like Oh that'll
be funny I'll try it tonight yeah but to
just sit and look at on the page and
like everything you do is stupid like I
can't it's just so flat and unflattering
that's what I like I don't like to talk
it out know that well talking right I
finally there's probably almost 20 years
I finally started listening to my sets
yeah to like put notes on it always felt
like the most arrogant self-centered
like listening to your own comedy like I
know I'm not listening to praise myself
it's to make it better but it just felt
felt gross I had I've had troubles with
it and the consistency for different
reasons just because I don't but when
you listen to it you start realizing oh
this would go better here oh I could
punch that joke up and hey sing his way
I know I always thought like no I said
it I know what I said no no when you
listen to back to it as a whole piece
it's like oh yeah this is all maybe
after two decades I should try and take
what I do seriously like I don't have
another career option so I should really
be focused on this more what do what do
you guys this has been my quest like
what do you guys do when you're not busy
like with comedy and all this [ __ ] like
what's your recreation that has nothing
to do with comedy or nothing do it
produce like what's your recreation like
I've been getting into hobbies like old
man retiree type [ __ ] lately yeah like
RC cars yeah I just sit there and [ __ ]
with those archery lately really yeah
that's been fun
not like hunting and seriously no not
sitting there with a bale of hay off in
the field no there's a there's an
archery range
five minute walk from my crib yeah
that's a hard city activity to get into
yeah you can't just go to the park which
is a big warehouse with targets and you
just go on and you just shoot [ __ ] see
that that's the kind of stuff that I was
seeking out just not related to any
showbiz [ __ ] or trying to like come up
with jokes almost like no just a hobbies
by myself ha because I'm not like in the
sports or anything or it's going part
like having to get a group of people
together and do something very yeah I
still never been a whirling ball ah this
guy's just found a new love for whirling
ball really yeah it's just twice over
the past three times we had a hell but
it seems hard [ __ ] fine it is hard but
then you sort of figure out a little bit
so the first game I remember it was I
don't think anybody scored the first
game as it was whirly ball made it
outside of Chicago yeah it's so much fun
man really you got to give it a try I'm
surprised I haven't done where I've done
like ax throwing and I'm like all these
other weirdo activity but whirly ball is
always one of those things like you
always said we're gonna get another
commercial local commercial like whirly
Baltimore's like it's go karts but it's
lacrosse but it's hockey but it's
basketball I'm like I'm not good at one
of those things and now you're gonna try
and put them all together I mean the
best part is you don't got a run you're
just driving a car around yeah and
everybody gets whiplash at the end of it
cuz you're winding up for a shot and you
get sideswipe it's not bad they're
pretty slow
pretty slow it's not that bad it's a fun
time no injuries maybe a broken fall in
here I want to do I want to top golf top
was top golf it's like it's like a
driving range but it's set up like
bowling like you get like there's
sensors in the golf balls so you hit
them and if you hit certain targets you
get points and everything so imagine
like a big old driver like different
like targets and all that stuff that's
sounds like good and you just drink beer
and do that you ever go to you ever go
to one of those shooting range things
where it's like all the stuff is going
on and if you hit the target
like a piano player plays or the cat
runs off I'm talking about the carnival
yeah yeah I've been to the carnival the
first ones like the ones that are like
real detailed and built out like you
can't just do build that up
I mean I'm shooting I've done that yeah
gun shooting I want hunting for the
first time a couple you know yeah a
quail with birds mmm shotgun yeah nose a
little bit like I did it and like I
don't think I need to do that ever even
have a good time I don't know man like
you get like the dog comes back with it
yeah bird will have its face blown off
and you did that like yeah did you eat
it at least yeah if you didn't eat it
you'd be an [ __ ]
yeah know where it was yeah well I'm not
gonna mount that anywhere is having its
faces missing I wasn't some prize just
be a weirdo it just mountain that house
yeah okay I'm bad at hunting check out
my trophies mangled animals when you go
to somebody's crib you just see mangled
taxidermy I'm a real bad shot what can I
say that one I hit by with a car that
one I mean yeah weird dude well it's
also really sounds sketchy it is because
you're just standing with people and
then a bird will fly up out of the
ground and you got four people just kind
of following it with guns and then it's
going left and you're to the left of
somebody and you just see the barrel
their rifle just coming toward you like
and we're shooting that we're filming it
for a show so there's a film crew on the
other side of the field that all sudden
came back like yeah we had some buckshot
kind of fall on us so we're gonna we're
gonna change angles cuz we realize we
shouldn't be in front of the guns man so
this is not a car I'm glad I tried it
and glad I know about myself that I did
that where can people see that that one
didn't make it to air that's very sad
for Esquire network and then like
alright this seems like it might be an
interesting show yeah Esquire network
went under
oh yeah okay then you know you think
about how much stuff you've made that
just never saw the light of day like how
many pilots you shoot
how many that just it's just out there
nobody's ever gonna see it all right
you've got a lot of X factors for
quality control I've got a lot of stuff
that can go screw you got mcafee coming
through on the laptop McAfee I've been
pretty good about keeping [ __ ] out I
thought it was a Mac I look at all kinds
of porn on my Mac nothing's happened but
I go to like the easy
I'm not going creepy pay for what you do
right you just trying to bring joy to
people Amazon no I'm a real in-and-out
kind of guy like five minutes I'm not
trying to linger yeah I feel bad though
it's like one of those things you are
partaking of it so you should be putting
money into it but then part of me is
like well maybe he's just looking at
porn so much I don't look at it a lot so
I wonder if like I don't know it's weird
like I still have like Catholic guilt
about it you know about for yeah how
many clips yeah how many Clips did I
have to go through to get the same
result that I knew it was gonna happen
and then forget about what I just did -
are you a tape on the camera on the left
side guy mm-hmm yeah oh yeah man I'm
into all the conspiracies of course I
got tape I don't I could put the tape on
a computer but I openly talk about it
everywhere I talk about everything I've
ever done but I don't want anybody
looking at me you don't put the tape up
there oh you know what so bring it
[ __ ] that's how I feel
bring it I know somebody who got like
hustled was something like that
yeah but it was more like like somebody
on faith like think you're just chatting
somebody on Facebook ID cam and then
they like alright now we got this clip
of you beating off we're gonna send it
to your family unless you give us money
you said I wasn't black mirror no well
that's like that's why because that [ __ ]
happens in real life
damn there's a guy you had to go and
like tell everybody look all right if
you get a clip I'm sorry but does this
situation I mean I don't have the money
to pay this person so yeah I wonder if
now am i setting myself up and we just
know you just told people am i
challenging extort us by saying yeah you
just talked about how you got your real
estate owner you see you mentioned you
got wealth and you don't protect
yourself man I playing with fire dude
although I think if anybody could handle
it and turn it around to a positive it'd
be you yeah man I'm relaxed I think
you're making a yoga pose right now
already about it I'll relax
no [ __ ] Hannibal look at yourself Camas
guy I've ever met
go on and look at me jerk off I don't
care man I'll make it work paid off of
it I'll start doing catchphrases when I
finish this clip just went down in value
I can't get money out of me no
[Music]
they don't realize how delicate you
gotta be about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how many episodes of love did you do -
so my butt was in the first show that
was a good show
you have assigned special paperwork for
that
yeah and nudity clothes yes you get
extra money for showing your ass no big
I had to pay them I did put Jim have
doing nude sing you ever get offered one
put your dick and balls and that like
that thing they put like wine bottles in
for like a gift city well untag beach
they had a double right show your butt
yeah I didn't but my characters just got
deep pants yeah if it was a fun if you
didn't like the joke there was a good
joke you would have done though if the
joke was just me did the fact that I had
on leopard okay
there's an immature joke and the movie
called tag I didn't think then it didn't
pop pop but then when I saw with the
crowd that's that's a hard thing about
making stuff that's not stand up because
you're like
you gotta trust somebody else's idea
what's funny and then you got a like
wait like that's the hardest time I've
had shooting stuff is like has nobody's
laughing you know nobody's I got no
ideas might be horrible and you just sit
with that in your head for months until
it comes out is there a person that you
work with that you fully trust thank
even it looks questionable on paper but
you're like I know this [ __ ]
gonna make this funny I don't do I don't
make a lot of stuff yeah TV movie stuff
yeah so I don't know you Bobcat Bobcats
always funny like I know that guy's got
a good eye for stuff then watching that
misfits and monsters I haven't seen it
much it's great is it it's great I don't
have cable anymore I'm sure I could
watch it online
I don't watch anything you know voice it
call me censor and you don't have cable
no hell's going on it's not like I just
give free cable from it I get a full
keyboard from them but now man I don't I
don't know what I watch I don't like
anything anybody's talked about I don't
know how people have time watch all the
game of Thrones
I just last week my girlfriend like we
should okay let's watch movies that
everybody's seen let's like watch a
series and so we tried to watch Harry
Potter we made like halfway through the
second one I'm like aizen's it's not
it's not my thing
yeah like sci-fi or fantasy and I feel
like I feel bad for I feel sad that I
don't have the imagination to get into
that stuff no I feel the same are you a
Star Wars guy no I hate feel the same
exact way you do about all that stuff
yeah I just I feel bad that I can't I
don't have the whimsy in my life anymore
like why can't I feel the joy off of
Star Wars that everybody else is yeah
yeah one fair right like what so what do
you get the joy from where do you go to
get that what makes you happy that way I
still just watch BMX videos that stuff
makes me excited you know most tricks
are still doing what old bicycles good
for them [ __ ] door to flip in the air
yeah still get that still gets me that's
my child is joy and Wonder
I still watch the x-games sometimes yeah
there's a lot of fun [ __ ] gonna you like
the x-games Hannibal I get jealous cuz
is some stuff you know that that you can
do whatever you want to do that's
[ __ ]
I'm not about to become a a top level
snowboarder or a skateboarder or a BMX
bike rider and that's it
but you want to feel that intensity of
soaring through the air and all that
[ __ ] right yeah even just doing a
loop-de-loop
yeah I'm not gonna do that you got
access to stuff go to one go to one of
these skate parks as a foam pit where
you could ride a bike off a ramp but
that you just land and a pit full of
chunks holy yeah you got damn right I'm
like I was gonna I'm 41 I was gonna go
to camp Woodward and it's like a summer
camp where as kids go there's a few
locations where they go to learn
skateboard it's like a summer camp but
for all those sports because they got
all those giant foam pits and stuff and
I just wanted I just want to do it once
cuz I could still go off ramps on a bike
and stuff but I'll get hurt but I want
to go I wanna lay in the foam yeah I
want to do that you guys have heard that
action park place in New Jersey
well there's the unsafest amuse that
sort that's what uh that lasts johnny
Knoxville movie did that come out
already
yeah I think that kinda but yeah do you
ever hear about act action Park no it
was it was a play was an amusement park
a waterpark in New Jersey and it was
notorious for being completely unsafe
yeah it's real rickety yeah [ __ ] yeah
they had a waterslide that did a full
loop and it was a - it was just the tube
and it did a full loop and then they had
a pool that they I forgot what they
called some generic like it was a wave
pool they call like the pool of death
there's some [ __ ] like that
like people were straight dying and
getting like serious injuries but the
owner of the place was like I want to
make an amusement park where it's you
know he was intentionally unsafe so it's
up to the kids
to be a stream as they use like I want
to make it intentionally unsafe you to
shoot guns into the water slides or
going down if you want to do that but we
use lighted up fired all the time
they're like in they'd have just
ambulances parked outside yeah you go
well there was that what there was that
place off Route 83 called like like doc
Finnegan's it was a water park and I
need to close it down because I built it
on top of a landfill so huh garbage
juice was seeping in the water park I
went it was fun
did you smell the garbage juice I mean
no it was a kid I don't know I thought
maybe like that just water parks smell
bad I don't know but they're like under
water slides and everything and yeah
water points are the best aren't they
I've got a water park right now go
raging rapids over by Six Flags
oh yeah that's so like there's so many I
love that that's like a gang hang out
that Six Flags has a gang problem yeah
like on top of like being in a gang
you're also like I need a thrill you
know it's like it's the gang is where
all the young thugs hang out really wave
them ball on our Western every time I go
there's little thugs got a bowling
they're not boners hollering at girls
they got a place to hang out where they
can get in I love they're like a
shootout happen but they're all wearing
bowling shoes and nobody can get away
they're sliding all over the lanes yeah
dug it out 24 hours a day you know what
the weirdest thing out was early 2000 at
for me as a thug but then I note
southern Illinois University Carbondale
man they had to close down a week for
Halloween right yeah because everybody
just burned down their own school that's
an institution of higher learning this
would be one paid to go to school and I
was dating a girl that was down there
and she's like yeah Halloween they have
to close down
well the price other schools were coming
to our school for just a [ __ ] just
started out we had a strip they would
come and it would [ __ ] up our school
they would burn [ __ ] rip trees out of
the crowd
but love cars you guys stand up for
yourself we have enough white traditions
[Laughter]
far as the wreck in the whole [ __ ] yeah
that was white people sit in Holloway
everyone got maced they threw canisters
like [ __ ] tear gas in there crowd
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] hit the fan and
no the right after that the Dean was
like that's it thanks Kevin brake is
getting split in half and y'all
[ __ ] are going home for all
away that's how a Halloween holiday I've
ever heard about that we were savages
back then we were known as the party
school we were like party school he was
like party schools but we were like in a
top ten a national party like yeah
biggest party schools in the nation and
I went to Columbia who no party that
Columbia no I did a lot of I did a lot
of ecstasy with people I met at Columbia
but I wouldn't say they were cut school
specific parties oh yeah man yeah man a
lot of day a lot of dance parties I
finished I finished school in Columbia
and I remember I went to a party party
because I met some kid from Loyola and
they had a no pants party and it was one
of the best parties ever because there's
like these really hot
those mostly girls they're really hot
and you were not allowed to wear pants
it was pretty awesome good enough that
you have like there was everybody's
pants in one room no just people were
walking and underwear just like okay
let's do this there it was there be real
shy shy wore shorts no it was actually
the opposite like girls were just like
[ __ ] and they just started taking off
their tops so like people basically
naked it turned it and I never went to
the party by the end no barriers no feel
chilly
what college did we perform at and then
after we got invited to some house party
new
oh the tiger list yeah yeah with the
tears out and says it was a I think it
was in California somewhere it was just
a table size party not every it was
spread you know kind of spotty topless
yeah everybody know I've been to those
well I god that's it that's the girl
that's she's freer than others I hate
when my masseuse leaves is halo Massa I
hate what my hibachi chef sneezes does
it bubble on the grill situational
sneezes I was getting them asides she
sneezed yeah just equated to snot
will you add often we've had a parlor or
was in your own home it was parlor it's
a massage parlor that's what they're
called
yeah parlor gets gifts it gives it a
shady cuz I always just put that cat
that's like a phrase that I just stick
with a massage spa it's like I still say
suntan lotion even though I mean
sunblock
it's a Sun Tan Lotion so do you ever
refer to a bar as a parlor because isn't
that where it I originally came from
like let's go to the parlor get a couple
designs usually it's a room in your home
parlor yeah you have a parlor it's like
your living room area Oh cuz I am well
I'm saying I had a massage in my home
once then you think that would be more
relaxing but it's worse because then you
got a stranger in your home and it's a
situation you're not used to in your own
home like oz isn't chill it's not just
somebody like I'm facedown nude my home
oiled up and they're just judging my
stuff well I can't see them yeah well
you just trusted you really put in trust
into their professionalism I've done
that a couple times because it is you
know pretty convenient come through and
then you get them aside and then they
leave and they just relaxed but then I
realize if I'm at a massage parlor they
got nicer stuff than I do like I still
got my crummy couch and [ __ ] like oh and
they're there you get though like the
water with the cucumber in it and stuff
like oh I don't have that in my house
yeah drink a miller lite afterwards I'm
like this isn't the spot treatment I'd
hope for yeah you start realizing a lot
of the stuff that you really want it's
just extra stuff is and it's super
accessible you just got to be thoughtful
you got cucumber water at your house no
[ __ ] to cut up a goddamn cucumber
throw it in some water you're gonna go
through that effort but then if I got a
cucumber I'm like I like cucumbers I'm
going to be dealt with ranchmen I gotta
[ __ ] up water water Oh
disposable cucumber right well I think
we just found part of your morning
routine there you go cucumber water you
can make a batch of cucumber water drink
that [ __ ] and then chase it with that
Miller Lite you were talking about hit
up them aside zapped right afterwards
mm-hmm righto massage a lot of masseuse
is on
you look up some ambient beats mm-hmm
offer the masseuse the cucumber water
then y'all flip it on them mm-hmm
can I get you a cucumber water that's my
problem when people are my home I want
to be hospitable I'm not used to still
having someone come to my house and then
also serve me that seems on and it's
really [ __ ] what I'm gonna be like no
you get on the table
how about today yeah you James your day
yeah making a mockery of their
profession doing it wrong how trippy
would that be though if you were a
masseuse and someone did that do you
like no go ahead get on the table
I'm I'm gonna treat you today because
you deserve this yeah I don't think that
would go over well at all I don't think
it's a big big fat is it is it free if I
massage you after you massage me of like
one in one out hey I don't have the cash
but I can rub you up so break even on
this shut up and let me touch you please
could change in the bathroom if you feel
more comfortable I had a stranger Asajj
experience once I I just wanted to just
get a massage and there was a place
across the street I was living on
Fullerton by California at the time and
the place was called AOL massage and you
know I could tell it's already a little
shady cuz you know they got the
everything's blacked out in the window
and it just says AOL massage on a
[ __ ] small awning there's I walk in
there and there's nobody at the front
desk but that I look at the sign and the
sign I knew right away like yo this is
one of those spots because it says it
said half an hour of massage it was like
50 bucks full hour of massage it was
like not that much of a difference 60
bucks and then it says full body lotion
massage a hundred and fifty I was like
what is this full body lotions
tip to tip yeah I still never pizzas to
a place like it was all blacked out
there's just looking like a slot window
in there and I just like slid the pizza
like thanks I'm like yeah I guess I know
what you do here but you gotta eat oh
yeah you got into the lobby just a foyer
and now I remember delivering pizzas in
one place they couldn't figure out they
couldn't get their address right zero on
a frontage road so super late were like
nine pizzas and it was one of these it
was like a topless massage place that is
called o'hare girls which is the least
sexy name O'Hara O'Hara girls oh yeah
but O'Hare girls layover ladies I just
imagine like a woman like like a shop
rag cleaning grease off her hands the
guy who's next
yeah a little hair girls and I walked in
Chicago Oh
backing up back in the mid mid to late
90s back around the turn of the century
for the malls or pizza no no my buddy's
place yeah it makes good good pizza pies
pizzas no there was like we always
delivered cuz all the corporate places
wouldn't deliver remember one depth like
there was that murder and they could
they murdered a pregnant woman and cut
the baby out of the womb what the [ __ ]
remember that I don't remember don't
member like all right of all the
legendary Chicagoland area there's the
Brown's chicken okay yeah okay brand-new
that one John Wayne Gacy
John and that but this one they killed a
pregnant woman cut the baby out the baby
lived so there's a kid out there they
got excavated out of his mother's womb
but that so like all the corporate
places wouldn't deliver pizzas to that
apartment complex Wow but we would
because ours is independent so we would
have to go there and as always well as
places where you put like different
amounts of money in different pockets so
if you got robbed like oh I got eight
bucks and you'd have to split up your
money
one time I buddy got robbed over there
and they took a pizza which I thought
was a ballsy move and what area is this
this is Addison it was like you know
where Dave and Buster's is
but behind Dave & Buster's ruff-ruff
hood but that was always like that was
always kinda like the like the you know
I was like that was the hood no it was
educational you get some people part in
I made it remember I'm making it like
delivering and get down the staircase
some kid open the door back it was a
pizza man gonna smoke some killer Doge
they're like yeah alright yeah my backup
but it was like him he was like 16 or 17
and then I was his mom like I know
people smoked weed with their families
and that's like okay but it still feels
weird yeah it's what it's like like a
mom and a 17 year old kid but also like
a 10 year old kid is it come on in here
man and it gave me a bowl to smoke while
the mom was just getting Pizza ready for
the family and there's a cold on a
second and he goes into this back room
and ice here all his glass shatter and
this kid just goes [ __ ] that comes Issac
man I had a four-foot out of 4-foot
graphics I was gonna have you hit I just
[ __ ] smashed it dude graphics anyway
man
chill out here and they just went 8
pizzas family and I just sat alone
smoking a bowl watching TV and the
strange apartment and I'm like I guess
I'm gonna go and there's like yeah later
I was like oh I thought I was gonna be
more of like a welcoming look we're
getting the pizza guys stone and stead
of just like yes in our house you ever
get the classic porn anecdote where the
sexy lady comes found no man that's
that's your temp that's uh you never got
that no man that's the urban legend I
like I thought there was way more
weirdos in the burbs than I'd realized
though of course in the city everybody's
just crazy
and you see them crazy but in the
suburbs everybody's hidden behind their
doors so when you know you get into more
places with a [ __ ] pizza than you can
with a badge so people just over there
house up the book yeah come on in you're
like oh yeah you guys are real [ __ ]
weirdos you know the amount of you know
there's one guy that I don't feel
schizophrenic or something but my buddy
would he would order pizza you would
understand him and you go to his house
and he's just beating his underpants and
you're like I got your pizza and he'd
just take off running like my buddy had
to chase him around his property to get
him to sign a credit card receipt he was
just a crazy guy at his underpants
that went run off like no way man gotta
catch me he's like what the [ __ ] is this
and that's just that's when you quit yes
that's just like a block down from a
high school that kind of guy lives there
the game was tough free post mates and
seamless oh man you'd never you trenches
in the trenches grew up screened all
them guys for you
hey weirdos gotta eat too man yeah
alcoholics that would pass out I passed
out on a pizza place here and I felt
bags I know it's a cardinal sin you
can't pass out on a pizza guy
now I'm gonna pass out but my my
security door was open so my main door
was open but then my secure door which
is like the metal screen was open so the
guy came to my door and just saw me
sleeping on the couch
I think couldn't wake me up and he can't
leave the PISA know excited to pay for
it
so no I called him back I was drunk and
I was so hungry like I'll give you a
give this guy $50 tip please come back
here with the pizza and he did he came
back and I gave him 50 bucks
but yeah the cubby came up and just saw
me sleeping on my own couch yeah and
couldn't like he's not gonna scream but
then he's like hey man hey knocking and
I'm just out there is knocked out right
in front of him it's like it's like
watching the plane you just missed going
down the tarmac like dammit I can't do
anything I called desperate I was
desperate
well you could have screamed if he was
really about that accident I saw this
video with somebody they left a note
they ordered a piece and left a note
saying my grandma is sleep upstairs Oh
scream Caitlin your pieces it yeah man a
guy's life is hard enough he's delivered
pizzas
[Laughter]
[Music]
how how does she say you chains in the
past five years five twenty twenty
thirteen now yeah I think I settled down
a little bit well I'm not trying wild
out as much oh yeah you got a girlfriend
now got a lady okay nice live with my
lady
nice I don't need I don't need to
collect as many stories right you know
when you're all your stand-up is based
around crazy stories and eventually like
yeah I don't want to have to be that guy
for the rest of my life yes in order to
talk about it or intentionally put
yourself in the situations where you
have to have a crazy yeah I just want to
be entertained by minutiae all right so
I think that's how I've changed we're
all right thank you for doing this man
appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you man thanks for having me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]